大家好 我是自由人
今天自由人要跟我的二徒弟
就是我交過帶過最厲害最厲害的地址
他在很久之前早就超越我了
但是他也在轉型
結婚了也生小孩了
所以很多人都在敲碗說
二师兄可不可以解答一下迷惑
其实我跟他的过程
他现在正在走我之前的路
就是从极短线变成流畅的波段
今天各位有什么问题的话
自由人已经整理好了
我再问他
我今天要跟各位分享的酒
是齐天资讯伟仁
伟仁送的这一瓶法国的Bushard
这个是他有一个gram
这里有个gram
gram的意思就是法语就是很好
好的意思盛大的意思
所以灌这个gram的意思的话
就是这瓶酒是有被认证
所以这一瓶不便宜
我查过不便宜
所以谢谢伟仁送我这瓶红酒
既然是这么高档的红酒
一定要配起司
而且是blue cheese
上次那個粉絲
自由人粉絲送我了一塊blue cheese
現在已經發霉成這麼黑
很臭超級臭的
從我的冰箱拿出來
整個都黑掉了
就是那個美啊
很美很多
然後現在是整個辦公室都是臭味
超級無敵臭
但是我相信它會很好吃
我們現在先來開紅酒
這瓶Gran的紅酒法國酒
法國酒就是比較variety
善變的女人也是這樣子嗎
這樣講會不會得罪
沒關係我的粉絲都是男生比較多
法國酒就是很多樣性
它會隨著時間
然後它氧化的程度不一樣
會有不一樣的風味
但是我覺得法國酒就是如果你要買就要買好一點因為買好一點那個感覺才會出來
好一點呢
沒有3000塊以上
我覺得很難買到我喜歡
3000塊我在買自立大概都買到那種旗艦酒了
所以今天我們來開這個2019年的
Boucher的Gram
好
相傳
大家真的可以來一下
這個呢
這個我們看一下它的顏色
它的顏色非常的鮮紅
而且是暗紅色
這個顏色就是對的
自由人對紅酒的理解就是說
你看到喜宴喝的紅酒
如果颜色不够深邃的话
它真的就是不好喝
然后这个是13.5%
所以这个%是够的
在口中尽量量氧化一下
因為我沒有醒酒
有那個櫻桃
那種很深邃的櫻桃的味道
還有那個黑莓味藍莓味
尾韻有那個回甘
像自由人真的是喝到曾經的
就喝到曾經
因為不管是喝得好
只要喝到好的茶他會回甘
然後喝到好的咖啡他也會回甘
就是喝下去很順
然後尾韻都會
那種感覺
台語叫
真的好酒好咖啡
好的紅酒都有這種現象
真的是很特別
果然是好喝的紅酒
果然是Gram
又等一下讓他再醒一下
不同的時間
他的喝起來的風味又不同
好 我們現在要來試我們的Crew Cheese
Crew Cheese呢各位覺得他味道很重那我建議是買這個蘇打餅所以又要幫全聯打廣告啦不是全家就是全聯
這個blue cheese
我這次買的是有蔬菜
這個叫什麼
蔥蔥吧
對 三斤蔥之類的
然後我們來吃配一下
blue cheese
這個是最好的享受
所以我這次如果再去紐西蘭的話
我會買一大堆起司然後紅酒直接吃
這樣子
這麼大的一塊
然後蓋上去真的太奢侈了
太奢侈了
超級無敵香
好香
可以有這種
涼涼的感覺
吃下去那個美啊黑的美啊
吃下去那種鹹鹹涼涼
然後甜甜的感覺
超好吃超好吃
我現在吃下去之後你就不覺得味道重
吃下去的感覺喔
不過其實吃下去的感覺就是
如入鮑魚之勢
那個久而不聞其臭
就是現在都不覺得是臭的
我覺得嗯 好搭喔
但是在旁邊聞的人真的會氣死
就好像那個榴槤一樣
有些人很討厭
好 OK
今天自由人要訪問自由人的二徒弟
我現在要叫他二師兄
二師兄可不可以教我一下
幾段線要怎麼打
好我們現在來訪問他囉
先打個招呼吧
大家好
二師兄叫做辛恩
蔡奇亞門
靠
還好吧
不會啦 心冷OK啊
好啦 我還是叫你心冷
我跟你昨天跟你聊一小時結果我今天突然吃球別再說了 我很疼當然你要問什麼我直接
今天我準備的幾個問題
是幫大家回答
第一個是極短線的轉型
第二個是身分的轉換
第三個就是適時的離開盤面
我先問你
這個是很多人
極短線轉型波段的手法
他會遇到什麼問題
我覺得你會
你的資金曲線會變不一樣
假設你之前極端的話
可能就很穩定往上
但我覺得
那個做長一點
或是做小波段會比較考
我覺得心理素質反而也很重要
就是你可能會先賠一段時間
然後可能會再抓到一波行情
然後可能又再
可能又再小回震彈一下
然後再抓一波行情
但是你手法不能改變
最容易你手法不能改變
因為很多人想說這個賠了
然後就換個手法
不行就沒賺到
這個很重要
我覺得這個很關鍵
所以關鍵點在於
你要你在週期的轉換過程
譬如說像我們之前都TickTrade
然後後來我最早之前是看1分K
因為那時候1分K是很乾脆很乾淨
就是紅 下一根就是紅
然後紅K 紅K 紅K 都實體的
我那個年代
現在都是上下隱現
對啊 而且我覺得以前做短就
比較不用考慮大趨勢
就是可能現在主要的氣氛是什麼
因為基本上它會動就可以做啊
但是你基本上現在會比較偏向
看長做短
你會主觀有一點方向
然後
假設方向跟你的部位同向的話
你可能就會下大一點
假設不同向的話
你可能就會下小點
大概是這樣
有人問說
現在的週期大概放到多大
就是我們本來是日內
Tip Trade到日內
然後現在我大概就一星期啦
大概就一星期
一個星期就是五天
大概就三到五天
所以你講大概就三到五天
就是你建倉之後你會
往那個方向爆部位
中間加緊忙
對因為
我覺得因為現在期貨
不管現在
因為我主要現在主要做國外嘛
不管國外國內也好
他們回黨都回很多
對 所以
我覺得應該在他發動
然後加速以後
沒有速度的時候先減一些
因為我覺得現在很少一波到底
那當然一波到底行情也是有
假設你當然要抓那個行情的話
你戶頭就會比較正當一點
這時候就考慮到你的資金控管
你資金控管好
推檔不會很多
抓到行情就會再又再上去
可是你資金控管不好
那你可能就會很容易爆掉
對就是等於你
你有瞬間放大加碼的時候
你在他速度消失的時候
你還是要走
對 這個可能還是短線的交易技巧
你看它動能不見的時候
你就先減一些
對 只是說看了比較長的周期
可能日K會日K
會看你
所以你還是以日K為主這樣
對啊 我現在是完全變成月K
我現在是買9月期貨
價格大格局
沒有啦 我還是一樣
我不可能all in
我也不可能去開槓桿
對不對
我做的就是要嘛就直接進週結算
要嘛就直接進月結算
我對的話
所以那個
那個我
我也經歷過經常被歸零
因為我現在都是做價內扣
我的多單
我永遠做多
所以我永遠是買價內扣
然後報到週結算
然後不是零就是一啊
不是不是5就是零
對
現在應該都跟以前不一樣
以前很多工作啊
現在大概就是一根過絕方向
對
所以我覺得就是
要從極短線變成這個波段
那個過程是很難好
但是還是一定要轉型
我覺得現在太短線真的很難
我覺得真的很難
因為我現在身邊認識的朋友
真的很少
TIK還做得很好的
好像就2021
大家賺到那一波航運的瘋狂
瘋狗浪
結果接下來就不好做了
好吧
我們這個問題我們就回到這邊
第二個是身份的轉型
就是你看
你從沒有結婚到結婚之後
現在有小孩
他這個轉型變成奶爸
你要帶小孩
跟交易會不會衝突我覺得我跟我太太算是還協調得不錯就是尊公合作
就是他早上就會他帶
我就交易這樣
有時候像我岳母或我爸媽來的話
反正他就會一起看盤
然後就小孩就給他們帶
給我爸或給
反正只有家人帶這樣
看盤的時候千萬不要抱小孩
他很喜歡拍我的鍵盤
或拍我的滑鼠
因為我的滑鼠會亮
我這些電競滑鼠會亮亮去這樣
他就手就這樣
看他亮亮就按一下就出去了對不對
對啊就剛好鎖到一支掌鈴鼓票
他就把我出掉了
還好沒有出
因為我有那個防待機制
滑鼠移開再移回去他就會跳回E
喔 OK
還好
好賺一根
我就有跟他 不要抱小孩坐單
就是就抱遠遠的就好了
對阿
這是因為你要帶他
因為在家裡面坐單
就跟月威士坐單一台一樣
但真的好玩啊
真的很可愛
真的是蠻可愛的
對阿
我跟你講
青春期之前
高年期之前
到小事都很可愛
小事前面的只有
你要享受這種人生
你現在都不可愛對不對
別再說
今天才被白眼
因為我沒辦法接他
他說我走得很累
他高中了不是嗎
沒有啦
國中不是嗎
不用接吧
騎腳踏車就好了
沒有
家裡沒腳踏車
都嘛
我早上是我老婆帶去上學
放學我帶回來
他說今天走多久
他說20分鐘很累
腳很痠
是大的還是小的
小的啦
他說辛苦了
不敢再講
多卑微
好啦不講了
就是這樣子啦
青春期真的很少惹他
大小姐脾氣
我的現在還很乖
你現在回頭
好好玩
有人問說
你一天會花多少時間看牌這個我也蠻好心的因為我做國外就是會比較久但是斷斷續續當然是白天會就是早上那個因為你做習慣了嘛白天股票台詞會還是會盯
就是會看
但是也不是說一直盯著看啊
大概都無聊就逛逛網
打打遊戲啊
愛惜也沒幹嘛
就是真的有比較大行情
Focus在哪個時段
哪個時段你會比較很專注
早上啊
早上大概10點以前會比較Focus一點
然後到現在就尾盤看一下
差不多啦
就跟我們打短線意思是一樣
但是現在真的是很不積極
現在就比較
賺夠了就不積極了
沒有啊節奏放很慢
因為你現在快啊
越快越
對我來講越快越快
下午爐
對啊
因為我留的國外的部位都是
因為我自己
當然我有帶Apple Watch
他只要打到停損
還說我設的什麼價位
他會通知我
我就會看一下
不然就是可能一兩個小時看一下這樣
自衛單啊
因為對啊自衛單
假設我有時候打一打
但是可能覺得今天偏空
我可能嚇一下
可能又被停損了
你會知道嗎
會去看一下
最主張就是我中藏了以後
手機都沒有訊息
那你想喝
對就是
對啊
航行
航行人一直以為
大大大大大大
所以就是要
欸 那個
你有外期嗎 海期嗎
主要現在海期下不見
數據呢
數據你會閃嗎
有時候就很難講
之前也是流
然後數據對
你可能當然就一下賺很多
可是有時候我發現
好像還是要減碼一些
因為我習慣掛停存
我不可能重床不掛停存
可是有時候被掃到那時候
去年有一個月賺一千
然後瞬間400就不見了
有一天啊
這沒辦法
那個就是宣布什麼要互盤
國安基金說要進場互盤
對啊
真的很白目欸
他前一天說不要
然後隔一天又說要
這樣才有戲啊
不還好啦
反正就是該來還是會來
所以有些時候這個
其實有時候變數是沒辦法避掉
其實也是希望讓自己的交易時間再短一些看到你的眼睛以後我就發現好像不能太常看盤就跟你講說不要真的真的
你現在38
你跟45
過了45之後
真的那個
連看辣妹的精神都沒有
那是因為你現在直播在講
你現在亂講我真的沒有看
我們認識這麼久
我身邊有女性朋友嗎
沒有啊
那你會不會懷疑我是同性戀
應該不是同性戀
可能是雙性戀
因為你有小孩
沒有因為我的心思沒有在女人身上
這一點倒是真的
你看我不會說
每次出去都是那一個
我一定不是第一個注意到的那一個
你可能是第二個注意到
最好
對啊都是你啊
不然你老婆交道
只剩下
這個我們再兩滾下去
不然我再拉下去
好
就是這樣啦
就是還是有數據的時候
還是稍微尊重它一下
稍微會閃一下
我覺得停損太遠了
對
好啦 現在就是說
做起來還會做交易紀錄跟檢討嗎
這個好像不用
如果那個月不順
或是那陣子不順
就是會做一下檢討這樣
這是我發現我問了很多高手
他們其實盤頭
其實現在好像做的事情也蠻少的
不像有些人可能一直都很瘋狂這樣做
包括我問很多
那種真的很厲害的人
差不多都一樣
小楊以前很認真啊
你看現在都沒有
我問他有什麼事
他就說你今天做怎麼樣
他就說12點
中島我靠他問問他
他就說我才當睡醒
沒有就是過那個
很有衝進
你剛剛來的時候很積極
2012年之後
每天都衝進衝出
你沒有賺到錢
然後自己就還不是在嗨什麼
你不覺得很奇怪
沒有吧
那我真的覺得有差
做到現在已經
十一二年了已經好像沒
有可能
現在行情不像以前
就是可以每天賺一些
或像2021那時候每天找
就是他沒有一個給你的期待感
就是點滑鼠就會掉錢下來這樣子
因為每天三五百點行情
他當然就是很認真做
現在沒有
所以旁邊的問題
所以你看我也沒在做交易紀錄
我們2012年認識到現在
我收完盤都沒有在做
我當時要做交易紀錄
做短好像就是比較不用
做短不需要
但是做股票真的要看它的基本面
但是看完之後
也不用再繼續看
因為產業不會改變
產業趨勢不會改變
在跌了
你要不要快點跑
我9月成本地萬五
我在怕什麼
這比一口小孩好怕的
也是
我現在開始打
我打下去
不要這樣
打得給你吃 我就說給你打了 我不可以啦
那沒有
我不是說一萬四 你殺到一萬四我就會加入
不會來啦
一萬五 你說一萬五不會來
你昨天跟我說你一萬五來的時候
你要怎樣 怎麼要捏爆
白蘭八組是嗎
我又打 到以前我就找你一樣 白蘭八組
萬五人來我中 你看
楊勳哥說我15000
他要把他單單捏爆給我們看
不是給你看而已
不是給大家看
你不要猜猜話題啦
你不要考得我很High好不好
叫我自虐
好啦停
我給你很跳
我給你拿來塞
好啦
好我們第三個
第三個就是
事實的遠離盤面
就是說你如果不看盤的時候
你會做什麼事
因為你等於是一天24小時有部位
那總是會有休息的時候
你的休閒時
會啊
你就是現在顧小孩
最近有在打雨球
然後有時候跑健身房
有時候就帶著家人
然後可能爬爬山啊
走走這樣
不會跟老婆雙人運動嗎
也會啊
好了年輕啦李莉亞
李莉亞好了
不要再深入了不要再深入了你幹嘛笑那麼敏懷還有那個啊你不是說要九團打暗雷士
各位朋友
這個暗黑士快出來了
只有人從暗黑一士27年前
我那時候是大二還是大三
大三
我在普大的時候大概是大三大四
我就暗黑一
然後再玩暗黑二
然後你來超辦事的是2012年還是
我忘記了
我是2012年玩暗黑3嗎
那時候你做起來了嗎
我在玩暗黑的時候
沒有啊 我剛去的時候好像還沒
我就看你好像正在打暗黑
哦 那是2012年啦
我來這裡要黑交易
每天都說暗黑
對啊
2012年不做單就賺了
你看我打暗黑不會賠錢
也是啊
你真的很認真
你那個A4那個紙都被你拿去印裝備
我都沒有看你的印線圖
我當時收盤之後有做功課過
我就跟你說盤中就要做功課了
盤中就要做檢討了
盤後檢討有個庇佑
都已經結束了
檢討了
成都還沒到那邊
沒有啦 現在你比我更厲害
不要這樣說
沒啦
打暗黑啊
我已經選遊俠你要選什麼
長信說他野蠻人
我打遊俠
我再看一下
你要我約誰打
快10個了
真的假的 那麼多啊
我這邊建勳我們就4個啊
大歐定棒建勳就4個啊
然後長信兄弟啊
長信兄弟
我就跟你講你就玩這個
然後你盤中你就玩這個
然後邊打邊打習貨
然後這樣一定很多人覺得很帥
然後一直donate你
沒那麼省
那是這樣子我幹嘛玩暗黑
我就一直打台子就好了
台子又不是好賺
玩暗黑不會賠錢
是啊 現在暗黑
說不定剛出來裝備很貴哦
打開來賣錢
可以賣嗎
可以啊為什麼不行
可以賣啊
這遊戲剛出來一定都是
你是把那個帳號賣掉是不是
不是啊
他應該是賣裝備吧那個裝備如果可以交易的話應該是賣的好像是可以接受就是我送好像是可以他的裝備是可以交易好像只有特定什麼交易
也不是全部
我們要打自己的程度
我跟你講
你就打那個裝備
然後你就拆直播抽獎
好主意哦
這個好
因為你不是要吸收你的那個
我覺得這樣的話
你可能會多個
你的訂閱會多蠻多的
就是因為會洗頭一些很多
不要想我沒想到
那一塊月
百萬訂閱近在此
百萬訂閱個頭啊
做YouTuber的甘苦談
真的是說不完
如何眼裡盤念就是做自己喜歡做的事情
像自由人最近要玩暗黑
我找了很多操盤人來玩
然後小梁我沒有問他說要不要玩暗黑
他說他可以直播世紀帝國
我說可是世紀帝國我不會玩
因為他世紀帝國很強
太複雜了
因為我只玩世紀帝國一
他世紀帝國蠻強的
跟我有得拚嗎
真假
怎麼叫跟你有得拚
所以你也很厲害
沒有
他真的蠻強的
他魔獸也蠻強
我跟你講
在旁邊直播嗎
你說什麼
我問你
你說世紀帝國還是魔獸
世紀帝國
蒙古啊
為什麼
因為他不用蓋房子啊
他不用蓋那個村民啊
他不用蓋人口啊
那他可以用在海戰
好啦其實我真的玩很少
你現在問到我了
想問好了
那個暗黑的時候
因為刷一個圖
刷一遍大概不用20分鐘
四個人刷很快
我那麼專業都還沒出來
你就是要怎麼玩
你又不是第一天認識我
我做什麼事都很專心
我已經做客廁了
好
我到時候再跟著你走
我會把傳奇專輩送給你
拿來抽獎
送給你
好啦
你就開課就說開課你就開課說上我的課送個黃金裝備哈哈哈哈不要拉
你想說要後跑嗎
那個黑空臉會花掉我很多時間
眼鏡又花掉了
不好了啦
我是休閒又不是職業的
不好了
好不好就是玩不無聊的
就是圓一下年輕之後的夢
你看我玩暗黑山
你那時候還在水深火熱
對啊
這三個大象都講完了
我就有人粉絲提問
粉絲提問說
怎麼從小賺小賠進化到
長線可以活在市場上
這個其實
我不知道你是怎麼樣
你說我
對啊 你啦
你說小賺小賠道
其實就是像之前短線
就是有辦法獲利啦
那可能就到時候短線
我覺得從
因為短線是很好訓練
那個執行力跟那個停損
所以你短線每天
每天一訓練一訓練
你自己就是腦袋
已經特有好單的念頭
我認為長線也是更需要這個念頭
就是你一定要很好的心態
然後你做長線才會想對
你知道我最近又突破另外一個境界
什麼境界
因為你隨時要準備你的市值
有從高點桌盪30%的心理數值
那是正常的
對1000萬
你如果是1000萬市值
兩星期變700萬
這是正常的
我發現股票其實真的動很快
我跟你講我上個月差點撐不下去
就是RTC在降上
回30%嘛
對
30%耶
不是說金額讓我
讓我憂慮
我還是賺錢的
還是賺錢
就是那個ZoroDang太快了
對啦
你說看剛才90%的
我當下我很想砍
你知道嗎
我砍了就剛好砍到阿呆
欸真的
就是阿呆了
我就是那阿呆
就是那個創意間
然後不是有一支股票跌頂板
唯一贏是不是
忘記了
我只知道說創意點
創意我有空到他破到1000
就不太久了
反手多上的不是很爽
比做空還賺很多
是喔
我在想說敢不報
我一定會變五百
就沒有信
相信副爸爸會讓他撐下去
我其實也在訓練
是股票做多
我猜在空
我是覺得長期
尤其是經過去年的空頭年
像我們都是拿比賽
其實我很確定12682北坤來了
我們也在問
你看德國股市創歷史新高
然後日本股市也創這30年的新高
只有大陸股市趴在地上
但是我們又不做那個
空很深
但是很難空
很抽
空恆生
他現在好像在打底的感覺
你空了他就抽上來
就是不好空
不好空
空的沒錢也是
空空空
不過我昨天晚上空了日本
很堅持
一定要做他乖離
修正就對了
做一根
你給我兩根就好
我要求不多
好了 努力所願
現在有了嗎
有了嗎
有了有了
有了
現在307啊
我空在311
小道沒有了
小道又起來了
我沒有空小道啊
我空日經啊
你做多上次不是很爽嗎
對啊
我也不知道在想什麼
跟你講今年開始永遠做多啊
空頭的時候
今年開始永遠做多就對了
我什麼時候跟你講說永遠做多
沒有嘛
我不是跟你講說我一直在等那個14年
等空頭
對啊
等他空頭
去年我跟你講這裡就是空頭了
這個是張忠雲大哥的給你的建言
對啊
我跟你講
我不是5月跟他一起演講
我
我們
演講之前跟演講之後
我有問他一些問題他現在就是長頭啊當然我們Label不太一樣可是你想想看他其實真正在期貨上很厲害的時候
是他35歲到38歲那個階段
他在2005 06就淡出市場
他叫期貨典款
他都沒做過
他可能是
那時候期貨他靠期貨賺不少錢
因為他是
可是我看他輸
他是股票先賺到錢
對 然後空那個
那個DOTCOM風暴的2000年
他從8000年一路空下來
再從3411911再做多上來
因為我知道的時候
他身上就這樣下去上來就賺3億啊
太省
近年哦
一輩子沒有辦法達到境界
對啊
能夠比你可能
只有我們認識的維尼
維尼那也是沒辦法
但是我覺得
我相信這個都是
真的要熱視啊
真的是十四招英雄
對我後來覺得其實都是十四招英雄
像你剛才講說
有人問說小賺小賠
我跟你講現在做極短線或是日內波
你能活著
就很假債
活著就很糟糕了
短線很難大賺啊
就是你很難
你很難大賺那一塊的話
那你就是小賺小賠
對啊
但是你的生活開銷就
就逼死你啊
你記不記得你怎麼去澳洲的
你沒有輸贏可是
每天都在耗損你的保證金
對啊
那一樣
現在我很多人問題都在於
盤難做對不對
然後他又專職交易
之前不管賺賺盈盈有賺
可能輸掉了
或是花掉了
現在很難做
看怎麼辦
做多啊
就跟著市人做多就好了
沒有人聽話
我說現在做多大家會笑
我覺得也是蠻偏多的
就是我覺得整個格局是偏多
只是會覺得說
你會賺那個乖離
因為我現在遇到
其實我一直覺得大家都會有這種問題
像你也是
像長信這幾天一直在空
然後那偉然
幾天偉然
他說他賺了一波之後
從上個禮拜就一直空
然後又吐回去我說那你想空的時候你不會想說我就休息就好這個很難喔
我覺得
我覺得現在不難
對我來講不困難
就是
你進階生活
對啊
我是說真的
我看你這樣
我常常看你
不是哪裡有哪裡飲湯
我剛剛在講
還是比他跟鋒鋼比較厚弱
那個比坐丹還難
我現在找不到那個鋒鋼了
上次我遇到神之手
他說你師父好像變成原始人
怎麼在過原始人的生活
現在好像過原始人的生活
不過他已經變真正的自由了
我現在又找到了
我要跟輝哥去瀑布旁邊紮椅
小瀑布啦
就是不會有那個
你夏天不怕遇到蛇喔
蛇一定會遇到
所以要防一下
就小心一點就好
要趕快拍個照
有時候馬上要直播說我被咬了
趕快幫我叫救護車
我現在的車子是哪裡
你不要這樣拍
我又講太久
能夠長期活著就是你要
慢慢的適應這個市場
就是有時候不好賺的時候
就小量精明
然後真的跑不下去
就跑Fu Panda
以前還沒有Fu Panda可以跑
之前那個很厲害
會跑的那個現在
你說精明喔
去年就跟我做那個誰啊
長榮行
我有一天賠100
我打很大
可能100多考完幾個
忘記
喔 好像喔
一次打就一支了
那天就一把了
那天七十啦
第二天三十了
一把就不下去了
我原本二月二三月之後賺一百多的
那天啊
來啊 喔四
這個又花四
開期
每次想要把四當一把就四
他如果一樣
他跟我一起被鎖住
而且那個那時候很奇怪
我明知道他會跌停
我就是不砍
因為我帳面上有賺100多萬我又來一支了
不要這樣說
每次都說每次來
每次來
打到我的停損
啊 到到的
休息了這個
這個又做白宮了
去改我休息一塊多月
沒想到不想進招反式
我覺得這樣是好的
我說好像重傷要休息
重傷要休息
後來就跟張董五月演講之後
就說趕不玩了啦
眼睛都玩壞掉
我還跟你玩短線
我就從此之後就小部位放場這樣子
再一次
有人又問說盤面轉折的時候
加空手加空單
真突破假突破
怎麼去觀察跟判斷
你看看好了
加空手加空單
然後我覺得
我覺得最簡單的方式
當然我們這種是不可能
不可能百分之百預測
歐盟只能用比較簡單的方式
就是盤酒必噴
噴酒必盤
大概就是這種
大概盤很久出去的話
也是試單
就是試
然後確定出去再加股微
也就是說
基本上也都是空不為空
沒有單的時候
他剛剛你空手的時候
就單子打進去試試看輸贏
這時候你停損放大一點
可是通常像我們這種不會被
其實像做久了
基本上都是先打
不會說空手
就是已經盤子很突破
基本上第一個反應就是先敲看看
比較不會說
比較不會有那種
空手的狀況
如果這也是你認定的手法
認定的賺錢的模式的話
基本上都是就是打不會迷失
因為賺個賺錢也是看他
到底真的走出去
如果他沒走出去
那你也就是那個就是假的
假的就假的
你不可能都每次打都真的
像今年從開紅盤
1月30號開紅盤
我記得我記得很清楚
大概是這個價位
橫盤區
你知道我每次在突破那個箱子的頂部
大概是15800 700
我每次都是多單
那第二天都歸零
就是到進結算就歸零
這樣來來回會好幾次
但是下面轉折我也多單上來
可是在上面我又會把部位塞進去
然後又下來
又歸零
反反覆覆到這一次我知道
我是對的
所以我就繼續報
好像選擇小紅現在
我要做這麼久
好像真的是不要買太遠
不不不
因為我認識的高手
他們都說他們都說遠的
對啊
他們都喜歡說遠的
我們要跟他反向思考
他說遠的我買進的
對啊
因為我都問你怎麼說那麼遠
你每個月開始不用說這麼遠
他說他這樣有時間去調整
慢慢動來調
而且真的出去
你那時候你再打
你再用期貨去數還來得及
可是我
你知道我不喜歡做賣方
因為我有陰影
那個陰影很大
但是做買方陰影更大
多大
我跟你講
做選這個跟現在做成
好像應該是還是要錢
是喔 我覺得也是
對啊
因為我每次都會
有大噴的行情我都沒做到
大噴都沒有大部位撐到結算
因為勝率太低了
你就覺得說
應該不會是這次吧
給你拿這些景色
其實我覺得
對我們來講沒有軋空手這個問題
比較少啊
比較少 特別是你沒在盤面嗎
大約不然出去
基本上手的反應就先按下去
就是很自然的反應就出去了
然後真突破假突破就看你
看你出去的部位有沒有真的賺錢
試的話再打
也是盤的比較久
就是當然出蓄的機率越高
或者是相同的股票
他盤的位置不一樣
出蓄機率也會有差
有的股票
大盤整個跌
他就盤在高檔
跟有的股票盤在中間
往上做機率
我覺得還是也會有差
對啊
所以你講到重點
你看
期貨這樣對不對
他現在創歷史新高就是要注意
對啊就非常有創意這個盤非常有創意非常有創意一直在抠訊你不要讓我去弄
這個應該是不會吧
我分享不行
你是說真的很創意
真的很有創意
創意很有創意啊
自由的人也很有創意
我不可以做個虎王夢
對不對
我不可以做夢
我在夢中夢到創意
很有創意
越南谷王
有人问说
现在的必杀技是做什么商品
没有什么必杀技啊
会比较偏多商品一点
就是因为你周期比较长的话
你可能就可以看多一点商品
那你多一点商品里面
你会比较说
其实都是类似的
比如说像我金银铜
大概金银啦
假设金银跟银的话
他今天發動我就會去找比較弱一點的
我會去找他日線結構去看
假設小娜跟小娜小到SP
我就會去看說今天如果他跌或漲
哪一個是比較弱或比較強
或近期比較弱比較強
你是做二哥嗎
就是有人先衝
然後跟著做第二強
沒有啦
都是做最強的
最強或最弱
我還是做最強最弱的
沒有辦法
做最強或最弱的
所以是相對性
大概是做最強的
這些商品有高度正相關
然後最強的
做多做最弱的
你有時候一定是
小科技股比較強
有時候又是比較傳產比較強
你大概就是會從
其實都不好做
但是這種方式其實會讓你勝率
長期還是賺錢
長期是賺
其實這個盯盤你現在都盯到幾點
晚上
其實就是
就是看一看一看這樣
因為都有設停損
有設一些警示價位
到時候會看
平常電腦前面就無聊
反正上上網打打遊戲
然後圖就在旁邊就看一下這樣
那這樣我知道
就是你都有警示
所以會設警示
所以我覺得科技的進步是很重要
如果以前沒有停損單的話
你可能一直要盯在盤面上
其實就是很簡單的功能
基本上就是停損單警示線就警示點到BBB就這樣而已沒什麼好避害的東西那就大同小異了我們再有人說
有人說問選擇權還是做結算日交易嗎
你現在還會做嗎
就是周結
很少欸
少了喔
基本就是不會說
我已經很少尾盤去做結算
我跟你講
你有一天啊
3分鐘賺100萬
你知道我們整個操盤是多high
多久大家都輸到
輸到頭
很早前啊
我們現在推動
很久啊
2017年的事情
對啊
我覺得現在
我覺得不知道
我覺得現在結算的行情很少
我覺得現在太多大咖在sale
那行情都壓著
像我就是預解一定會在盤面上
像禮拜三我就看狀況
我大概只會打12點半到12點45
我以為就會很爛
那個要用一些極短線交易技巧
就是掛單
進場跟掛單有一些技巧
這個我不想講
因為講了之後
幹就沒錢賺了
那個流動性很差
這個東西還蠻差的
你的必殺技
我的必殺技
連工我送的時候
我再直接公布
公布還是要恰取一下費用
我把我的必殺技講出來
我就沒得賺了
老的好啊
這隻老的好啊
沒有啦 我不可能一直看半
我集團現時會在12點半到1點
這個時間做
我不要跟你交
這給你啦
那以我啦
你怎麼施捨一下給我
幾萬塊而已
最好啦
我現在是尾盤都做的
結算是做的
懶懶散散的
除非是可能有比較大的消息
或怎麼樣才會去賭
不然都真的
下禮拜
好 沒問題
我通常都是估一個旅約價
都要掛成定
他通常不會拉太遠他頂多只能跑一個旅約價已經很久沒有看見跑兩個領略價真的我覺得
除了上禮拜三
那個也沒有啊
那個是開盤就開始拉
我說尾盤
對啊
現在的尾盤都沒行情
他是上去又下來啊
盤都算很多啊
後來那個才回50點
那個差很多很多
超多的
對我來講
還是會想說我要不要先走的問題
後來我想說
那是跟電話說就好
我覺得現在好像是報告尾盤比較好一點
對
反正也是賺錢
你看到的高點不是高點
看得到吃不到
套句
我們小良哥講的
怎麼說
你可以不用出在高點
但你可以出在高位
哦 他這樣說
對 我想他的口
我想他這樣說
觸動我的心
當時啊 當時啊
有啦 我剛認識就是我去上那個
那個什麼聚才課啊
我叫你這麼的嘛
我剛他跟我說
就是反正他課裡沒有講說什麼
就是不要想要出在高點
但你可以出在高位
因為我都說你是唯一打起來的
事實上你是做台紙打起來的
那你覺得你有什麼人格特質
覺得你很適合打這個期貨商品
台紙尤其是台紙
台紙喔
我覺得台紙還是一個
你可能
你該趕的時候要趕
然後不該趕的時候就是要相對守
我覺得這個是要訓練
可是我真的覺得台子真的很難
真的很難
至於說撤子就是我蠻敢賭的
如果說我認為這有行情
我其實還蠻敢下很大部分
賭我是對的
對啊就是會想要這一把賺多一點這樣
會想要投大一點
其實我現在也是這樣
但是我賭的不是極短線
我賭的是我的人生的
最後一次的警示循環的低點
我跟你說十幾年
我當時跟你說一直買一直買都不要吵
我們認識十幾年我有跟你講這句話嗎
沒有
從去年我就一直講
今年我一直講
我跟你講明年我還會這樣講
你講著講著太子又彈起來了
對我就說永遠做都不好嗎
又彈起來你看我多有
這個也不直播啊
你又彈起來
不要再打開啦
去年很多人做不好
像我還好 因為空頭盤
牌子波動到我就可以賺錢
只是沒有像以前賺的很多而已
像有些人像長信他們去年就不好
他就小賠
去年做古奇的人反而做不好
對呀不好做
那有人問說
問你說去年
去年做的怎麼樣跟今年比有什麼差別
空頭就比較適合我
去年算還可以
空頭是比較適合我
今年的話我覺得
就是今年就是
我發現今年應該是股票好做一點
但是股票好做也是做比較長線
像你這種比較長線的
沒有 股票你做收場
因為期貨你就是
我也是兩三天啊
股票其實也是都兩三天啊
有時候收場停隔天如果覺得很強
可能就爆一天大概就兩三天這樣
那太短了
我跟你講
今年所有任何追高的股票
回頭一看都一倍
有啊 很多都輸掉
然後都在中間
我都輸在中間
我這輩子就是等這一波
那我就拜拜
再來跟我屁事
我可能已經60幾歲了
我等他回檔
不可能
希望市場能夠給我
不是假如自由人團隊的機會
不可能
一萬五
如果來我電給你看
好啦
最後兩個
最後兩個 我很疼我會想要好苦
有人問說當初去澳洲打工前的心情跟打工後的心情我感覺差不多多少差不多多少就是說打工前跟打工後
就是口袋裡面多了1萬澳幣這樣
所以心情沒有改變
我覺得你回來也沒什麼變化
因為你回來不知道到底行不行
到底行不行這樣還是
因為你那時候還在還負債
大家不要認真
請你把我的交易人生看清楚一點
這種問題不要再問了
最後一個問題
很重要
如果人生再重來一變的話
你要什麼時候買房
真的有人這樣問
為什麼會問這個問題
因為你從來自以後有錢可以買
沒有啊
就是像我們
因為像我自己的自己比較偏短
但是所以我的策略是會
我還是希望我的會比較
當然是現在你現在回來看
你一定說一定是買在
買在什麼SARS啊
買在什麼2000年啊
買在2008啊
你比較
我們做期貨的都比較沒有安全感
如果手頭沒有保證金的話
就沒有子彈
會怕
其實我們當中其實用不到那麼多
對嗎
我當中跟你說買房子的時候是幾年
我已經忘記了
對啊 你就一直叫我買房子
對啊 如果你說你要現金買
我說你才會去扛
現在你再給我生出來不是一樣
這個笑欸
好啦這個都過去了
至少有買房
對啊
當然是有買
我今天在念長慶
我說我不是叫你買房嗎
你還是買那個什麼
M4
他買440
他就甩一台了
我就說我不是跟你說有錢買房
現在房子很高
先買房子就是居馬泡
有車有馬就可以泡
你讓他講到嗎
我忘記誰講了他買了那個車子之後整個人就退那個已經脫胎換股了
走路都有看
是喔
我都說
因為他們家隔壁
剛蓋
我說在蓋裡面有沒有去問
爸爸去問早就賣光了
人買多少
好像他是滑下
電力滑下
你說在哪裡 在郊西嗎
沒有啦 我們家 他們家隔壁啊
我家那邊啊 宜中那邊啊
他們家隔壁 新蓋了
我說欸 你家隔壁那個已經在挖地基了
我說趕快去問
他就跟我說賣光了
建商他在還沒
在預售就賣光了
就是都沒有
他忘記了 我只記得總價
車位100萬
宜蘭大概是三四年前
房子總價我記得好像800多萬
更便宜欸
對啊很便宜
趕快沒有
完壽了
就完壽了
再挖地基就完壽了
現在已經漲到天上去
至少是1200起跳
1200到1500左右
看是多大房數
你們現在宜蘭是這麼瘋喔
改天來宜蘭看房子
你就開著你的那一台
我帶你去看房子
我出去穿一張拖子
南拜託跟你說不要插我
沒跟你說 人家看這種南拜託
人家覺得那幾千庫名牌
我們打比賽
我們講買房子
我老婆有一陣子很喜歡去看房子
然後他就
宜蘭人也不會特別打扮
帶我們那兩個去看房子
然後進去因為他沒有特別的打扮
也沒有開什麼
一樣開TOYOTA
那時候他還開VS
進去之後就沒有人鳥他
然後我老婆就有點不爽
然後就開始講英文
講完之後就有人靠過來
真的假的啦
真的很勢力
這哪招啊
真的啊
全程講英文啊
是喔
對啊
可是應該要講台語啊講台語人家覺得你是很強講台語鬆鬆鬆鬆鬆鬆
OK 這樣很久了
好快結束
就這樣了
好啦就是最後一個
就是你給有心要做專職交易的人
就有什麼建議
我們做個ending
如果很有心的話
我覺得不一定要專職
就是你可能可以
研究一些長線的策略
等到真正賺錢
因為現在的
我認為現在的市場
你要做短線
真的很難
如果說以股票來講
除非你是發動者
除非你是
你是主力
不然像
大部分的我覺得
真的很難
所以你倒不如想一些長線策略
等他行情大跌的時候
然後你去接你幾個設定的股票
對
這樣會比較舒服一點
因為你長線的話你就需要時間跟他
跟他那個不可能
你又沒有收入
對
好啦
我還是不建議長線
總結就是你還是要有
被動的收入
然後可以讓你
圓這個夢
交易的夢
對啊
除非你年輕
加雷少
然後又存到一定的收入
然後可能拿一小部分出來試
那你可能可以試看看專職
這個也是我一直提倡
就是不要放棄你的工作
因為做機會
離開這個交易市場
你什麼都不是
這個也不會
又不是說現在是2021
如果說現在是2021
還是說那時候以前國劇很瘋
在2015還是2011
那時候股期
反正就是那時候股期很瘋
很多人在做
就是那時候你真的
那時候真的就
那時候就很好做
現在難做的
過了
真的過了
我覺得大家不要對焦
專制交易存有很多幻想
就是把你的生活顧好
然後再來想交易的問題
而且不要
但是很值得
很值得一試
就是可以試試看
但是就是不要
30歲以後不要進來
30歲以後
有然後結婚又有小孩
真的不要進來
真的會毀了你的家庭
但是就是做長線投資是可以
可以
策略不要太偏投機
太短線機我都還好
那就跟我一樣做個
自由人非常有創意
做個古王的夢啊
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕